So tell us how you got involved in GPU's with the first place.
&gt;&gt; It goes way back; I was actually an undergrad.
I was working on some of the original SGI Octanes with OpenGL
and discovering that actually some of those OpenGL Octane machines for doing graphics--
you know, the kinds of image processing you do in OpenGL
could actually be used for simple computational things like fluid flow.
So 1 of my undergraduate theses was to study fluid flow and simulation
in the OpenGL pipeline on an old SGI Octane,
and then went on to Stanford, did a few other things but came back to it eventually
and that built a career out of it.